how are you I don't know if I should I
introduce myself I don't know if you
know anything about me but why don't I
just say a couple words I I was I grew
up in Ohio that's that's my that's where
I came from I went to college in Ohio I
i was on a peace corps for two years I
was in the country of Thailand in the
late 60s I came back I was football well
I not dead famous but I I played
football I was a little bit too small I
started at a high estate and I thought I
need to go to a college where they need
me so they I went on my smaller college
denison university and i told you i was
in the Peace Corps I came back I was a
small businessmen I was in the state
legislature for 10 years I was in the US
Congress for 24 and I was an ambassador
that for about three and a half years in
Rome to the World Food Program the FAO I
fat and related UN agencies and you
would think with that kind of that kind
of background that it would be hard to
be humble i mean i'm here with tony
blair and speaking at yay like you know
but you know politicians we get pummeled
all the time and i remember an
interesting story that happened to me
when I first was running for Congress
and it was in dayton ohio and it it was
a very tough campaign and not partisan
not mean but you know we had something
like twenty six debates and there was a
lot of money spent and anyway it looked
like i was going to win the last two
weeks and so a friend of mine came
running in and you know it was in a room
like this you know with my supporters
because we were deciding what to do in
the last two weeks and he said Tony
you're not going to believe this but
Time magazine is on the phone they want
to speak to you and I thought wow Time
magazine I mean you know when a reporter
knew your name in those days it was
really something especially somebody
from Time magazine
wasn't even elected yet and I'm thinking
this is exciting I've really arrived and
I said well get the name I'll call him
back in 10 minutes so they did that and
I talked to my friends and supporters
there I said well what do you think this
is i want to say three things i said
this is my chance to really make a hit
in the united states and i really want
to be heard on this issue so everybody
said it sounds good I said let's get
that person back on the phone so we did
and this is what she said and I'm
thinking here it comes this is my debut
in the United States and she says Tony
would you be renewing your subscription
to Time magazine obviously I don't read
Time magazine anymore and I 25 years ago
I probably would have if you were to ask
me to talk about faith and poverty or
faith in anything faith in politics I
would have I would have probably laughed
I made my my my love of God my
foundation of any kind of faith or
religion was was lacking I mean I didn't
even know people that know anything
about faith matter of fact I had to go
to the Congress of the United States to
find God can you believe that and it's a
long story i won't go into it but anyway
I fell in love with this person called
God and fell in love with his son and it
changed my life in a very interesting
and remarkable way I so today instead of
trying to talk to you about poverty and
globalization the sunny part of
globalization the dark part of
globalization and talk about the
readings that that you have that you
have read that were required of you I
read them too I thought maybe I would
try to talk a little bit about the
practical aspects of how I think faith
and poverty really go to
other and bear in mind of course this is
pretty much my own experience it's what
I feel it's what I've experienced I
think it probably first started when I
was in Congress I won't talk about the
faith part but i'll i'll bring it up as
I go through this but I was chairman of
the Select Committee on hunger in
Congress and this was in 1984 and we
were hearing of these alarming calls for
help from Ethiopia and it was the time
of the major famine there and and they
had had civil war there was a drought
civil war and they had a hideous
government then and the government I
won't go into the kind of government
they were but they they had this whole
issue of famine from from the public and
it was about five or six months before
anybody could get in there and figure
out what happens matter of fact it was a
BBC crew I believe it they got in there
reported to the world I felt incumbent
upon me as the chairman of the Select
Committee to go to Ethiopian to take a
look at it see it try to understand it
walk around in it and I was taken back
by it when I went there because I went
with mother teresa's group when we went
to a little town about two hours above
at us by light plane and we landed and
we went to this medical clinic there and
as soon as i walked in i noticed there
were thousands of people gathered
outside and they didn't look good i mean
they they really looked like they were
just ready to pass out and as soon as i
walked into this clinic it was very
small clinic probably no larger than
this room doctor grabbed me and he said
come with me outside I've got to show
you something he said because we can
only pick five or six kids he said
there's at least three thousand out
there they're all dying and they have
been walking for about 100 miles in some
cases
and they haven't eaten whatever water
they had is dirty they're sick or not
only dehydrated but a lot of them were
dying and and so as I went outside with
him I people just kept handing me their
children they thought I was a doctor and
half the kids I saw were dead and we
could only take 5 so 5 were taken into
the clinic and the rest died and I saw
three days of that I had never seen
anything like that in my life and I you
know when it came back from that trip I
said to myself you know we do a lot of
things in Congress that really don't
amount to much and this is what i
thought i would do I would spend my life
trying to work on these kind of issues
so I began to travel and I've been to
well over 130 nations some nations I've
been to at least a dozen times North
Korea seven or eight times the Congo
Sudan you name it I've been there I got
involved with projects and and as I
began to do this I began to read the
scriptures and both the Old Testament
New Testament matter of fact it's the
same in the three religions of whether
you're jus or Christian or Muslim you
can't help but get you can't help but
see the various issues that God talks
about relative to the poor there's over
2500 verses in the Bible that deal with
the issue of the sick the poor the
hungry the people in prison the orphans
the widow's the elderly and God is very
clear on it PP once it's involved and so
as I began to grow and as I began to
pray very privately on this not not
realizing how I was going to present
this because I didn't want to wear my
faith on my sleeve I didn't want to look
like a hypocrite at the same time it was
beginning to be an authority in my life
it was beginning to be foundation and as
I began to read proverbs there's some
great verses in proverbs of
it says in so many words that God says
that if you if you help the poor you
honor me he also says in nineteen he
says if you are gracious to the poor and
I'm paraphrasing you lend to me God
doesn't say that many places says if you
help the poor you'd lend to me and you
honor me he also says in the famous
chapter of Matthew 25 you can look that
up but you know he talks about the least
of these but I really respond to that in
my life and as chairman of the Select
Committee on hunger it really it it
began to make sense it was a way that I
could bring God into my workplace it was
a way that I didn't have to I didn't
have to preach about it I didn't have to
scream about it I didn't have to shove
it down anybody's throat it was a way
that worked for me and it was away on
which I could I could say that you know
I'd rather see a sermon than here one
and it was it was a great time for me
and just about the time that I I was
really we were really producing a lot of
legislation and in my committee was
what's called the conscience of the
Congress by the New York Times and we
had won all the awards and I mean we
were and we were the most bipartisan
committee in the Congress anyway the
Democrats at the time and I'm a Democrat
decided that you know we had high
deficits pretty much like we do today
and they decided that you know we have
to make some kind of a move to look like
were you know living within our means so
they decided to start cutting their
committees and the first one they cut
was my committee now I'm really mad what
do I do as a politician you know my old
ways were to get back at them and to
figure out a way to hurt them but i
thought you know I'm supposed to be a
new kind of a person here supposed to be
thinking in a in a different kind of way
and I went home and I told my wife I
said you're not going to believe what
happened here
they took this thing that I believe in
so much away from me and what the what
the Congress failed to tell the people
they were going to take the money away
that we spent on the committee and they
were going to give it back the American
people but the fact is the Congress kept
it and they never gave it back to
anybody so now I'm so mad I'm so
frustrated and I went home and my wife
said did you ever think about fasting
yeah I thought you got to be kidding I
it was a difficult time so we we went
and read the scriptures on fasting and
and the most famous one is Isaiah 58
from the from the Old Testament let me
read it to you shouted aloud do not hold
back raise your voice like a trumpet
declare to buy people their rebellion
and to the house of Jacob their sins for
day after day they seek me out they seem
eager to know my ways God is sitting
there talking about the things that he
doesn't like he says why have they
fasted they say and you have not seen it
why have we why have we humbled
ourselves and you have not noticed yet
on the day of your fashion you do as you
please and you exploit all your workers
your fasting ends in quarreling and
strife and in striking each other with
wicked fists you cannot fast as you do
today and expect your voice to be heard
on high now this is the kind of fast
that I want you to do this is one
constant this is this is the real kind
of fast of a day to Humble himself it is
it is only for bowing one's head like a
reed and for lying on sackcloth and
ashes is this what you call a fast this
is where he says is is not this kind of
fasi and I have chosen to loose the
chains of injustice to untie the cords
of the yoke to set your press free and
break every yoke is it not to share your
food with the hungry and to provide the
poor wanderer with shelter when you see
the naked to clothe them not to turn
away from your own flesh and blood
then your light will break forth like
the dawn and you're heading and your
Healy and we'll quickly appear then your
righteousness will go before you and the
glory of the Lord will be your rear
guard and it goes on and on and on
that's Isaiah 58 so my wife and I were
reading that and I went out to a few of
my friends people that I trusted people
that were wise and I said look I'm
thinking about fasting I'm not going to
eat nobody's ever done this in Congress
it seems kind of strange and you know I
don't want to look like a clown but what
do you think of this and you know they
liked it so this was a way I didn't tell
anybody that this was my inspiration
because if I did that they would
probably censor me and throw me out of
the Congress but based on this and based
on the fact that my wife was with me and
some of my friends I went before the
Congress the United States outside the
capital and I said look this place
doesn't have a conscience about these
issues and I am going to stop eating no
I'm not going to hurt myself but I'm
going to stop eating and I'm not going
to do anything I'm not going to do
anything until something good happens on
hunger because I'm sick and tired of
this place you know taken away these
kind of issues when in fact this is one
of the more important issues that we can
deal with so I'm thinking well this is
the end of my career nobody will ever
understand this my staff thought Tony
you'll never get elected on this one
people won't understand this and I
didn't really try to explain it so I
went back to Ohio I thought I figured
well how I might as well face the music
and get it over with and so I went back
to all my press back there and I just
happened to be speaking to a high school
that day and I explained to them what I
was doing and and why and very
interesting they all decided to fast
with me everybody in the high school
students
faculty and their families now they did
I fasted for 22 days I didn't need for
22 days I just drank water they took two
or three days amazing thing about it is
that caught on and there was about
10,000 high schools that fasted with us
couple hundred universities and the
press began to write about it in a very
interesting way and a very wonderful way
very warm way both on the left on the
right I'm really surprised and a lot of
good things began to happen a lot of
programs started the legislation was
starting to pass people really being
cognizant not so much in the Congress
because there's they still don't know
what to make of this guy that's
fascinating a don't understand this one
anyway a lot of good things are
happening around the country and in the
end the thing that really got me to quit
is the the world bank called me and they
said you know we're very moved by this
fast we've been reading about it and we
were going to have a world conference on
hunger and poverty and we want you to
come and speak and tell us about your
fast which I did and what I was done and
when it was all over they they committed
a hundred million dollars to the fast
what a million dollars went out from
that one fast and went to poor people
all over the world mostly to women and
went for microfinance microcredit so
they could start their own jobs I tell
you this story because it was an example
of way that I could bring God into might
into my workplace without really talking
about it very much it was a way for to
it was a way for me to love God it was a
way for me that I felt that was that it
was necessary and all I did was I
stopped eating I didn't have a campaign
I didn't have a team I had no money
I had nothing except I believe this and
I believe that God would somehow honor
it and I was kind of testing him to see
what would happen i was i was pretty
much scared though i really i was i
figured my career was over but i guess i
tell you this because I it was a way
that I could bring faith into my
workplace its kind of kind of like what
Mother Teresa said to me a couple times
at one time I visited her in Calcutta
and I was pretty young then and I said
to her as we were she was taking me to
the poorest section of Calcutta and she
said or I said as I walked and I saw
these people just masses of people lying
around some very sick but people just
living on sidewalks and you had to step
over him i said to her i kind of blurted
out look at this where do you start how
can you make a difference and she didn't
say anything to me she there was a guy
in the street an older man and she got
some people to help bring him home to
her place to her hospice and her her
area where she took care of the of the
poor and the dying and she began to wash
him off and just love him and touch you
and a point was she came back to me
later and she says look you do the thing
it's in front of you and I know that you
know you're going to hit a lot of you
got one of the finest Prime Minister's
here in the world he's just been an
amazing man what he's done and so you're
going to hear a lot of talk and a lot of
discussion about faith and globalization
but the one thing I want you to do if
you think about it just do the thing is
in front of it you you don't all have to
go to Calcutta you don't all you've got
all kinds of problems here in New Haven
and just do that one thing if everybody
did that one thing half the stuff we do
in government we wouldn't need but we
don't do it so those are things i want
to leave you with I'm trying to give you
the idea of how does faith work this is
the way I think it works I think you
have to experience that I think you have
to walk around in and I think you got to
do the thing that's in front of you I
think you got to trust God and if you do
this and if you do it with sincerity
you're going to be amazed what happens
so that's what I wanted to say to you
today thank you very much